hey what's up my name's Samuel Leeds and
in this video I want to explain what
service accommodation is serviced
accommodation is something that has
completely revolutionized most property
investors and landlords finances and if
you've heard about it but you don't
properly get it then you need to watch
this video if you've never heard of it
then you really need to watch this video
but firstly do me a big favor smash the
like button on this on this video that
would really help me and it'll help the
YouTube algorithm so serviced
accommodation is when it's a way of
renting out a property so instead of
renting out let's say you've got a
little studio flat and it will fetch you
four hundred pounds a month instead of
renting out four four hundred pounds a
month you rent it out per night have you
ever wondered this why does the average
studio apartment rent out for about four
hundred pounds a month but a hotel room
that's smaller than a studio apartment
that doesn't come with a kitchen just a
bedroom or went out for about a hundred
pounds a night that's a hundred pounds
every single night that means in four
days that room would have generated the
same amount as a studio apartment in a
month it doesn't make any sense why
would you rent out your property to
someone that's going to pay you a
monthly fixed fee when you could rent it
out on short-term stays that my friends
is what serviced accommodation is more
and more people are doing this and my
I've got hundreds of students that have
become financially free with just a
small very small portfolio of properties
by using serviced accommodation so these
are things that you need to look for
when doing service accommodation the
first thing is demand if you've got a
property could that property or that
bedroom or whatever it is that you've
got could it be rented out by the night
is there demand in the area and you can
check that by firstly thinking well is
there hotels in the area I've seen
situations where there's a hotel and
next door to the hotel there's a room
the room is being rented for a fraction
of the price of the hotel why is that
if the hotels get in business then maybe
people if they knew existed would win
your boom so is their demand if there's
people around if there's shops and
there's busyness and
tourism there probably is demand if
there's hotels that are full there
probably is demand you can check a
website called air D and a and air DNA
will give you an idea of the demand of
serviced accommodation so that's the
first thing as they demand the second
thing is if you're going to be
considering renting your property out of
serviced accommodation is how are you
gonna market this the reason that hotels
are able to fill up and make a fortune
is because everyone knows they exist if
you type in on Google hotels in and you
type in an area boom it's gonna come up
it's gonna come up on booking.com and
all the different websites here's the
great news for you did you know that you
can list your property your home your
bedroom you can list it on the exact
same sites booking.com
is not just for the elite hotels
booking.com is for the little guys as
well you can list your properties on
booking.com I mean people are renting
out their properties their rooms as
serviced accommodation in other words on
a short-term stay on a short-term let's
on air B&B on air B&B so there are lots
and lots of websites where you can list
your property and these sites spend
millions of pounds marketing your rooms
and it costs pennies to do it or they
will just take a percentage of the stay
so you don't have to pay big investments
to get this died so is their demand
number two is you need to list your
property in the right places number
three is you need to check the
legalities now what are the rules around
serviced accommodation do you need a
license to be a serviced accommodation
owner do you need a hotel license no you
don't do you need staff no you don't
anyone can do this the only thing you'll
need to check is if you've got a
mortgage on the property you'll need to
make sure that the lender doesn't
prohibit you from renting your property
out on a short-term stays that's the
main thing also there are some areas
such as Greater London where they say
that you can't rent out your property on
serviced accommodation for more than 90
days a year so you do need to check
because there are some areas that do
that but generally speaking across the
UK you do not need any kind of license
anyone can do this if you do need a lie
if you happen to be in Greater London
you can need to get planning permission
you're gonna need to change the use of
the property and then you're going to
need to work whether it's worth doing
that or not so that's the third thing
rule number four is actually doing this
how you actually going to do this are
you gonna change the bed sheet so you're
gonna list it on all these sites so how
is the systemization side of things work
if people are coming and going every few
days does that mean you're gonna have to
let them in and stand at the entrance
and keep in this is gonna become a job
so no it's not here's how the system
ization works so what you're gonna do is
you're going to get a channel manager
and the channel manager is going to and
you can use companies like a VEVO that
will do this and the channel manager
they all list it on all the different
web sites like booking comm and
different things like that so that so
that it's marketable and then if they
will have an online calendar system an
online booking system so that people
can't double-booked so the first thing
is a channel manager then you're gonna
need to have cleaners and the cleaners
are going to be the people that they're
gonna come in and come out and they're
gonna lay eyes with the online calendar
the cleaners will liaise with that and
every time someone leaves the creams are
gonna come in and they're gonna then
make it nice ready for the next person
and you might pay a clean on average
maybe about 12 pounds an hour and you're
also gonna need a key safe outside the
property so that when the guests get
there they can let themselves in let
themselves out and put the key back
they'll they'll be fined if they don't
put the key back they'll be charged and
that's all gonna be in the terms and
conditions on the agreement which is
going to be sorted out when you
systemize everything with your channel
manager now does this take a little bit
of getting used to and you need to
figure this out yes you can figure this
out yourself and you can do if trial and
error or I mean I do offer advanced
training and I'm gonna be running a
webinar soon about service accommodation
if you're interested in doing that just
there's a link below in the description
where you can click on the link put your
details in and you'll be the first to
know when I'm running a free advanced
training session on serviced
accommodation so that's the that's the
fourth thing and then the fifth thing
lastly is if you're doing service
accommodation it's really really really
important that you stage the property
nicely and what I mean by this is you've
got to make it look fantastic you've got
a furnish it you've got to make it give
it the wow factor how would you feel if
you went into a hotel
and it was really bland and there was
beige walls so you want to kind of make
it look like a popping beautiful room
now you can do this very very cheap it
doesn't have to cost thousands of pounds
it can just cost hundreds to turn a
really bad property or really bland room
and it's something that's really really
popping so listen guys serviced
accommodation I think is a very very
very profitable excellent way to rent
out a property where it's gonna double
triple or even quadruple your profits if
you want to see more videos like this I
can show you me turning a really basic
property on a shoestring budget into a
beautiful room and you can watch that
video right here I'd suggest you would
probably check that out also please do
subscribe to the channel you can
subscribe right here don't forget to
smash the like share this video around
so your friends can have their eyes open
to what serviced accommodation is as
well and if you enjoyed the video drop a
comment in the comment box below thanks
so much I'll see you next time